- What up, YouTube?
Just got out of stage, out of stage?
Off the fucking stage,
here in my green room
and wanted to really tell
you that I felt really great
about this keynote that
you're about to watch here
in Washington DC, actually in Virginia.
Actually said DC and someone's like DC?
I was like, oh, fuck it.
And, then I said, you'll see
me say DC but later Virginia.
Really excited about it, a
lot of mindset strategy stuff
and a lot of details in the opportunity,
and just one more hard squeeze to the neck
of the opportunity we're
all living in right now.
And two more shots to the neck.
Number one, if you're not
subscribed and I just looked at it
and most of you watching this
right now are not subscribed,
it would mean the world to
me to give a little subscribe
to the channel because
we're pumping out a ton
of good content in the video experience.
And number two, First
in Line, First in Line,
First in Line, I'll leave
a a link in the copy.
If you do not know what First in Line is,
it means you have not signed up for it.
It is my text message
and Facebook Messenger
CRM system where basically,
all my coolest shit
goes to first, I want
you to be a part of that.
Please sign up, enjoy this clip.
(audience cheering and applauding)
What up?
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Thank you, sit, let's
get every minute in here.
I love you back!
(audience cheering)
I see you, I can hear, let's go!
Thank you so much, thrilled
to be here, DC area.
Excited, want to talk about
a bunch of things today,
but I really want to
focus on the mentality
and then the execution.
The biggest thing that I've
realized over the last decade
is that, people break
into two different camps.
They either get really mindset oriented,
motivation oriented, education oriented,
come to conferences like this,
consume a ton of content,
get really up here,
and then the break down
to why it hasn't happened
comes in the actual execution.
Then, there's people who
are doing and executing
and making and producing content,
starting a business, executing,
executing, executing.
But their mindset is
broken or more importantly,
when I think about it,
one of the biggest things
that I think is not clicking
is they really don't have it figured out
from a finish line standpoint.
I was saying in an earlier
session, I just had that
one of the biggest things
that I find fascinating
is that, if I was analyzing myself,
Andy K, get up here, I got you, I see you.
Andy's live-streaming and he's struggling.
Let's give it up for Andy K!
(audience cheering and applauding)
Right here's good, Andy,
you get nice and close.
Good job, buddy.
Fuck, I lost my thought, Andy.
(audience laughing)
I got it, I got it, I'm
kidding, I'm kidding.
It's really interesting,
I was saying in a session
right before that, if I was
analyzing what I've done
in business for the last decade,
I would actually have
a lot of issues with it
if I read it on paper and
didn't know who I was.
Lacking the context, what
was I trying to achieve.
Over the last decade, I've
left an enormous amount
of economics on the table.
Done business deals that
I think a lot of people
in this room would deem
as not a good deal,
not the right move.
If you didn't know that
I was trying to buy
the New York Jets, they would seem stupid.
If you did, they would
make a ton of sense.
I think one of the things that people have
to ask themselves here,
both on a personal level
as a human and then on
a professional level
of what are you trying to achieve,
is do you actually even understand
what your finish line looks like?
So many people are caught
up, so many people here
unhappy because they're just living to pay
for the box and the container
they've made for themselves
by buying that house or
that car, or that thing,
just literally stuck
because they put themselves
in that position, oftentimes
to keep up with the Joneses.
But often because they just don't know.
Real quick, I'll get
right back to my keynote
but I have to make a
reference here real quick.
You guys cuddling under
that blanket is the greatest
fucking shit I've ever seen in my life.
It's not that fucking cold.
(audience clamoring)
You guys are fucking soft!
I mean, if you think it's cold in here,
you've got no chance of winning out there.
Get your fucking game up!
(audience cheering and applauding)
Guys, I was born in fucking
Russia, it's not that
fucking cold down there.
Get out of here, that American shit.
(audience laughing)
Alright listen, listen.
I love it.
Guys, listen.
I think what I love about
this is the interaction
we're doing right now, this
is the best, I love the stage.
What I hate about it
is, I don't have context
on you one by one.
Right, what I love about meeting
with somebody individually
or knowing Andy, who works with me is,
by having the context, I can actually get
to those subtle little pieces.
When onstage, I've got to keep it macro.
I try to go micro but I
know that everybody here
has different shit.
Here's what I can tell you a couple things
that really make sense
to me in a macro talk.
Something that I know is
fundamentally universal
for everybody there, there, there, there,
anybody in this room.
One thing that I know is
fundamentally universal
is that, nobody is gonna cry for you,
they have their own tears.
One thing I'm positive about is how ROI
negative complaining is,
and how much I'm trying
to suffocate the practice of it.
I really have been fascinated by people
that have changed their
mindset into understanding
that everything that is
not going well right now
is their fault.
It has been remarkably important
to me in understanding that
everything that I'm not
happy about, is on me.
It's a remarkably interesting brain twist,
the amount of energy spent on
things that you can't control
versus being accountable
to what you can control,
has been a huge separator
for me in the last
four or five years as I've dug deep.
And so, of course there are
things that have happened
to you that you can't control,
but if you were able to leave,
if I was able to have
a couple things happen
out of this talk this morning,
one is just self-awareness.
Just like, do you
actually know who you are?
So many people wishing there's something
instead of understanding what they are.
Number two is accountability.
No question, the quickest way
to happiness is accountability.
When people start looking for
somebody else to be at fault,
whether it's the government or their aunt
or their fucking boss, they always lose.
The energy really matters and so,
I've been thinking a lot about mindset.
I've also been thinking about
passion a lot more recently,
even though the first book
I wrote was a lot about
your hobby or your niche is your power,
ironically, I've come back to it.
I've given a lot of thought
to what makes you tick
and how realistic is the long tail
of the internet to get there.
I am stunned by how many
people here don't realize
that the quickest path to happiness
or more economics in
business, given the context
of this talk, happens to be in the thing
that they love the most,
yet they're not willing
to eat shit for the next three
to five years to get
there, let me explain.
It blows me away that, if
you're ridiculously passionate
about the Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles,
now stick with me, I know
this is going fucking weird,
that starting your Instagram
account, your podcast
and your YouTube channel about
Leonardo and Michelangelo
and putting out that content
for a three-year period,
in the long tail of the internet,
in the way that niche marketing works,
if you focus on that 7:00
PM to 2:00 in the morning
around that world, that
literally within three
to four years, the practicality,
if you're consistent,
to making between 50 and
$100,000 a year in affiliate
eBay links and sponsorship
around being the foremost
expert of Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
is a very fascinating thing.
Now, that may be a very rogue
example for a lot of people
in this room, but I'm desperate
for you to understand that,
if your passion and
knowledge is around eating
and living vegan, if it's
around sneaker culture,
if it's around fashion or peanut butter
or whatever it may be, you
need to leave this conference
and debate one thing.
The most fascinating time
of day for me right now
in the world is 7:00 PM
to 2:00 in the morning.
You would not be at this
conference if you were 100% there.
You would not be here
if you were 100% there.
That's just facts.
So now, I'm curious about
how many people don't see
the world that I see.
It was funny, Andy and I, on the way here,
saw a video that I'm gonna post,
you'll see on my social
very soon, that we dug up
from 2011, where I
basically tell everybody
to invest in Amazon, right?
I go, everybody's talking
about Facebook and Google
and Apple, but weirdly, I think Amazon.
2011, people didn't
realize how big Amazon was.
And, it's interesting
when I look back at them,
like fuck, I said that seven years ago,
what did I see?
It's the same feeling
I have right in here.
When I look in the, you know,
what's so great is I can
see your face right now and
just realizing how many people
are chasing money.
You know, how many people
here and across this country
right now rushed to buy cryptocurrency?
Because that's where the gold rush was.
I'm just fascinated by people's
passion for the quick fix
versus the marathon.
I'm fascinated by people willing
to put shit in their body
to lose 15 pounds, that's
some private label horseshit
from China versus fucking
eating right and exercising.
(audience cheering and applauding)
Let me let me promise you something good,
and that's how I want to say it.
Everything special is fucking hard.
That's very true, right?
It is true.
I don't understand, you
know what I find funny?
That this collective room,
and when I say this room,
I mean this whole fucking
country doesn't realize
the following data point, which is
that if you make $440,000
a year in income,
you are in the one percent.
That, in America, one of the
richest countries in the world,
the top one percent
starts at $440,000 a year.
A lot of money, however,
everybody is walking around
right now talking like, if
they're not making a million,
that's just like the
entry point to making it.
We're completely missing perspective
of what's going on out there.
We're missing perspective.
People are fundamentally
confused of how hard it is
to be at that place, and by the way,
let's talk about real privilege.
Forget about money, how about this?
When are we gonna start
talking about the mindset
and the happiness of it all?
So, for me, what the internet represents,
the reason I get passionate, somebody sent
a great tweet today about being
in line at this conference,
and they're saying,
they said the people in front
of them were talking about me,
and the one person said,
he's good at Facebook!
And the other person said, oh shit,
I thought he was in real estate.
And I was laughing.
I was laughing because
what's really interesting is
I'm an entrepreneur in a time
where entrepreneurship got cool.
How many people over 35, raise your hand.
All right, so all these old fuckers,
(audience laughing)
for all the kids in here,
they all know a world
where entrepreneurship wasn't cool.
just for all the kids
how many people under 30,
raise your hands.
(audience cheering)
By the way, I fucking love
people under 30 so much!
(audience members cheering and applauding)
Can we please use this conference to stop
the hating on millennials please?
(audience members cheering)
Seriously, I love how my friends and older
act like we didn't have lazy fuckers
in our generation either.
Honestly, I genuinely believe
the millennial generation
and I watch very carefully, is literally
the most unstoppable except for one thing.
The biggest, under 30, raise your hands.
(audience members hooting)
Honestly, you've got this, the only thing
you have to promise me
is you have to understand
one thing about business and life,
that you have a disadvantage of,
you haven't been punched in the face yet.
It's true.
The only thing that is your,
your vulnerability isn't
the entitlement and all the other shit
that everybody else says,
we've had plenty entitlement
in fucking America for a long time.
Your biggest problem is
you haven't been punched
in the fucking face yet.
Since you've been grown and in the game,
the economy has been phenomenal.
Over 40, raise your hands.
Us fuckers have been
punched a couple of times.
We were you in 2007 when we
thought we were fucking fresh,
until the economy got
its fucking ass kicked.
The only vulnerability you
have is you think putting
entrepreneur in your profile
means you're an entrepreneur.
(audience members applauding)
So, a couple things, number one.
If you're not winning right
now during nine years,
and don't get it twisted,
it's been nine years
of economic growth, nine
years of economic growth,
if you're not winning now after nine years
of economic growth,
after we got bailed out
and we didn't want to pay the piper,
well then, you fucking suck.
And, I want to stay on this for a minute.
If you think you're an entrepreneur
and you've got a business
and you've been doing it
for more than two years,
and you're not successful
during a fake, propped-up,
bailed out economy
after nine years of
growth, you're not good.
Now, maybe what you're
trying to build is not good
and you are good and you
just missed it this time.
But, I need everybody to take
a real reality step backwards,
because listen, I'm here
for one agenda, I'm selfish.
(audience member laughing hysterically)
Yeah.
I am, I'm selfish in the
fact that Caleb, were you at?
No, Caleb, you filming?
I can't find you, Andy, where's Caleb?
How the fuck did you get up there?
I'm selfish, for Caleb
who's filming today's vlog
and for Andy, I'm here to
be historically correct.
I'm here to be historically correct.
So, when I stand up here and
say, if you're not successful
in your business and you've
been doing it for two years
on nine years of economic
growth that have been propped up
by a bailout, that you
suck, I'm not saying that
'cause I think I'm fancy up here.
I don't, that doesn't do me no good,
that's not interesting,
I'm saying it because
you have to be self-aware.
Happiness comes from self-awareness.
The number 19 at Facebook made a lot more
than every other number one
of every startup, period.
There's a lot of people
right now that wanna
put entrepreneurship and
owning their own thing
on a pedestal because it's cool now,
just like Harvard used
to be cool 20 years ago.
And just like I didn't fall for that,
plenty people here I don't want the fall
for the entrepreneurship thing.
How many people here are entrepreneurs?
So, raise them high, I want
to see it one more time.
(audience member hooting)
You got that, you got that down.
So, for everybody raising their hand,
one more time, I apologize.
I just want you to look around,
let me promise you one thing
that all the people
with their hand up know,
this shit is lonely.
How many people work somewhere,
raise your hands, it's cool.
Love it, let me tell you the best part
about working somewhere,
you get to blame somebody else.
What sucks about
entrepreneurship, one more time,
hands entrepreneurs, everything wrong
with your business right
now is your fucking fault.
How many people here have
more than five employees,
raise your hand.
Every employee you blame,
you fucking hired them, dick!
(audience laughing)
Every single thing
wrong with your business
is your fucking fault.
That's what sucks about entrepreneurship.
The other thing that
sucks is, when the economy
does correct properly, and 90,
let me say it one more time,
hands up, 90% of these
people go out of business,
that fucking hurts when
you have to go get a job
and everybody makes jokes about
you changing your profile.
So, the glamour that we're
putting on entrepreneurship
right now, in a world
where more than ever,
people are scared to have Ls
on their resume, scares me,
'cause that leads to depression.
That leads to a up place.
I come here DC, with one agenda in mind,
which is, I really want to make
sure that people leave here
knowing who they are.
Do you understand yourself?
Do you actually have a situation
where you judge yourself
within yourself, or do you
allow other people's opinions
to dictate your life?
There is nothing, nothing more difficult
than navigating your life based
on somebody else's opinion.
And, if you really reverse-engineer
so many of your actions,
you will be devastated
by how much is being done
based on somebody else's opinions.
The great gift of my life
has been the evolution
of my process of not going
there, by going away from it.
And, how many people here
are parents of kids under 15,
raise your hands.
Let me just go on this
high horse for 30 seconds.
All, all, the far majority,
all's too absolute,
the far majority of my
happiness, today as a man,
is predicated on all the
adversity and losses I had
in the first 18 years of my life.
If there is nothing that scares me more
in our society today, it's
eighth place trophies.
(audience cheering and applauding)
I don't like kids crying
any more than you,
but eighth place trophies
and fake environments,
and all this adversity
that we're trying to strip
out of kids, every fucking
person in this room
was bullied in school.
We all took our Ls.
We all had a weird year or two.
All of us, some weirder than others.
Not you, Andy.
But, we need to start
putting losses and adversity
on a pedestal, not hiding it.
(audience applauding)
As somebody who's really
over-indexing on Instagram
and Snapchat, just back to
parents here real quick,
just real talk, something
I've never said publicly,
if you and your spouse are
going through a rough patch
and you're fighting,
and it's not on point,
and your kids are seeing it,
and then you go to Disneyland and take a
photo with the family
and make it seem like
everything is fucking awesome,
you're setting up your kids
for some terrible shit.
(audience applauding)
Keep that in mind.
And, you can use that
example for all the under 30s
that may not have a family,
fronting, posturing,
or my favorite that all
of you bought in to,
fake it until you make
it, look the fucking part.
Let me tell you for all
the homies that live life
looking the part.
For all you fuck faces
wearing fake watches,
and a suit that you can't afford
because somebody fucking told you
that you have to look the part to win,
let me tell you who you're
fooling with your look the part.
Other fucking losers.
(audience applauding)
The quickest way for me to know somebody
goes in the L column for life
is when they're faking
it until they make it.
It is absolute horseshit
out there right now
because of the way communication,
listen, I'm all about this.
This is the fucking game.
If you do not put your mobile
device and the platforms
that are on it on a pedestal,
you were actually irrelevant in society.
You don't like it, cool,
I don't give a fuck.
It's still the truth.
Especially for this audience,
if you're in business,
if you're making business
decisions based on you
being angry at technology because
kids don't look each other
in the eye anymore,
if you're running your
business based on your ideology
of how humans should be
interacting with each other,
you will lose.
I love when people walk
into, like my favorite is
when you judge, when you
walk into a restaurant
and you see a couple sitting there
and they're both on the phone,
and you hit your partner
and you're like, oh,
that's so terrible, right?
Like they're not even talking,
you think that's so terrible.
I think it's phenomenal.
I'm being dead serious,
Let me tell you why, especially
for the over a 30 year old
crowd because they're gonna
remember the world this way.
Back in the day kids, when people
didn't have fucking phones,
I saw that same couple 15 years ago.
Let me tell you what they did.
They sat at dinner,
across from each other,
and they didn't say a
fucking word to each other.
Now, at least, they could
be doing what they actually
want to be doing.
(audience laughing and applauding)
My friends, technology hasn't changed us.
Technology hasn't changed us.
Technology's exposing us.
Everybody wants, you guys really
love to blame the Russians.
(audience laughing)
The Russians didn't go in the poll booth
and fucking pull the lever, you did, dick.
(audience laughing and applauding)
Let me tell you how
Facebook Ads really run.
They put in front of you
that you're gonna respond to.
We're getting exposed.
we're not changed,
there's no overlord robot,
Zucks is not controlling
your fucking mind.
We just don't like being
accountable to anything.
Accountability, my friends.
You put accountability on a pedestal,
your life will change.
Do you know how liberating
it is when you realize
everything's your fault?
It gets real fucking good out here.
When you actually realize
everything's your fault,
it gets really good out
here, because when you think
your boss's boss controls your shit,
when you think somebody down
the street in a building
controls your shit, then you get real sad
because you feel helpless.
When you realize you control
your shit, things fucking go.
And so, now, let me switch
into what you can do about it,
now that we've established
that mindset thing.
If you do not understand
that Facebook Ads,
Facebook Ads, so whoever
was in line saying
he's good at Facebook,
you're fucking right.
If you do not understand that
Facebook Ads, running ads,
not posting organically
on your page and getting
a couple likes, running advertising,
spending 10, 30, 80, $900
on a post to a specific group of people,
which is why you made the video
or picture in the first place
that has an agenda behind it
around your ambitions to
be the mayor of your town,
sell some fucking sneakers,
or whatever the fuck
you want to do with your
life, right this minute,
fucking August 22nd, August
22nd, 2018, right this minute,
right this minute, right this
minute, August 22nd, 2018,
Facebook advertising and
Instagram Story advertising
is the most under priced real
estate grab of human attention
in America ever, period!
(audience applauding)
How many people here have run Facebook Ads
and something good has
happened for their business,
raise your hands.
(audience members cheering)
How many people here have run Facebook Ads
and something bad has,
it just didn't work,
raise your hands.
Own it, don't be a dick.
(audience laughing)
Facebook and Instagram
ads are no different
than a basketball.
The ROI of a basketball
for me is negative,
I've had two meniscus tears
and they cost me some money.
The ROI of a basketball
for LeBron, a billion.
Facebook Ads work.
If you're sitting in this
crowd and you're like,
Facebook doesn't work, Facebook Ads work,
you just might not know how to play it.
And, if you don't go
home from this conference
and sit down and Google and
YouTube and read and watch
videos for 10 hours to learn a cult,
do you know many people here have opinions
on Facebook Ads, yet
they've never run one?
If you do not go home and
learn how to run a Facebook Ad,
and then do it.
Like, within 24 hours, if
you do not leave this talk
and run a Facebook Ad
for your business service
or a ambition, well then,
what are we doing here?
You can't read about doing push-ups.
You've got to do push-ups.
If you are not producing
content for Instagram, Facebook,
Snapchat, Twitter, LinkedIn,
YouTube, these platforms,
if you do not produce
written words, pictures,
or audio or video for
the seven to 12 websites,
the apps that dominate
the attention of America,
you have no shot of succeeding
to the level that you want,
because either you are
massively limiting you're upside
or, and this is the funny part,
how many people feel like,
how many people are having
their best business year ever?
Raise your hand, raise it high.
First of all, let's clap it up for them.
(audience applauding)
One more time, best year so far?
One more time, hold it up, I
really want to see the people.
My friends, on some serious
shit, you're the people
that I'm most worried about.
No, I mean it, I'm being
dead serious with you,
here's what's happening.
It happened in 2001 to
2004, something came along,
it was called Google.
People didn't know exactly
how powerful it really was.
A product came out called Google AdWords.
At first, Google just had results.
Then these little ads started showing up.
At first, they cost five cents a click.
I, as a young kid, when I
when they were doing my bio,
which, by the way, who wrote my bio,
my mom must have written that bio,
it was fucking ridiculous.
(audience laughing)
It was going on forever, I mean, like.
And he sneezes on Thursdays!
(audience laughing)
Andy, can we please fucking fix that?
It was way too long of a bio.
Sorry, I was like, just couldn't
wait to get out of here,
I was like, shut up!
What's completely fascinating
to me about this is,
Google came along and when
they did my bio, they said,
and he built his dad's
business from a three
to $60 million dollar business,
and some people clapped,
one guy made of loud noise.
And, I'm literally back
there and I'm like, loser.
And the reason I said
loser, and I said it,
and I say it every time
because that will always be
in my bio, that's my origin story,
because that should have
been three to $250 million.
And it should have been
three to $250 million
because I had figured
out the moment in time
and it was called Google Adwords.
I was buying every wine
term you can imagine
for five and ten cents a click
and they were all working.
But, I was too young and
I didn't fully understand
what was happening, and I
spent money on direct mail
and radio and print and television
and other internet shit,
and WineSpectator.com,
and a magnitude of other things.
How many people play poker?
When you have the nuts, you have them,
and you're supposed to
go all-in, and I didn't.
And I had them.
And then, I went my whole
career, did well, did my thing,
but I never had them, and I have them now.
And I'm trying to give them to you.
it's called Facebook Ads
and Instagram Stories Ads.
They're the fucking nuts.
(audience applauding)
Let me tell you exactly
what's gonna happen
from this second on.
98.9% of you are gonna
get super fucking fired up
by my keynote.
And then, next Thursday's gonna happen.
And some shits gonna happen,
you're gonna lose a client
or something bad's gonna
happen, da, da, da,
and all the good vibes and
energy are gonna go away.
And you're gonna go back
to defense and passive
and not offense.
98.9% of you are literally
not going to take the action
that I'm asking you to do,
which is figure out how
to convert your message to your ambition,
whether you're a landscaper,
selling a T-shirt,
whatever the fuck, dentist,
I don't give a fuck!
(audience laughing)
The reason I say that
is, I don't give a shit
if you sell concrete wholesale,
this is gonna work for you.
But you don't believe me.
I'm serious, I know, I fucking do this,
this is fucking Groundhogs Day for me.
I spit this shit selfishly, you know why?
In seven years, I'm gonna
run this fucking video
and you're gonna see it and
be like fuck, I was there.
(audience laughing)
And the videos gonna be
like, I fucking told you so.
And there's gonna be a Wall
Street Journal article that,
in the year 2000 fucking
15 to 19 was the golden era
of Facebook 'cause it only
cost five to six dollars CPMs
and $2, $3 CPMs on Instagram, and now,
they're 50 and $80 CPMs.
I know it because I've
seen this movie before.
You know what's fucking awesome
about being 42 and not 24?
Context.
I have context, I've fucking
lived it, I've seen it,
I've watched it, I lived it.
Do you know why you know
who Prince, Madonna,
Michael Jackson are besides their talent?
They fucking hacked MTV
when it owned the attention.
You know who else fucking hacked MTV?
Fucking P Diddy.
You know why P Diddy fucking won?
He use to get out of his ass in his office
and run to TRL when Carson was on,
and just go on set
uninvited, 'cause he knew
every fucking teenager
in America was watching
and he was stealing attention.
The attention is one
place, you don't like it?
Cool, sorry.
Your grandparents didn't
like Elvis either.
And people here judged
Miley Cyrus eight years ago
for what she did at the VMAs,
which now, eight years later,
is like a lame Instagram post.
Culture moves, things move.
We're sitting in a weird time.
Ask me, ask me why I wasn't
making a lot of content
in 2011, 12, 13, 14.
Not, oh, thank you OK, yes.
I didn't mean ask me, dicks, calm down.
The reason I wasn't making content
was there wasn't anything this ridiculous.
It was business as usual.
Twitter, Facebook, YouTube,
they were maturing,
there wasn't anything special.
It wasn't outrageous,
it wasn't a great buy.
You weren't buying Malibu
beachfront property.
You weren't buying Manhattan.
You weren't buying great property,
it was properly priced,
it wasn't under priced.
Every single person here,
regardless of her or his ambition,
has one agenda, to get
the potential person
they want to talk to attention, and then,
they have to talk and
execute for their action.
we have not seen a more remarkable
under priced opportunity
of people's attention
than we have right now,
specifically on Facebook
Ads, Instagram Stories
YouTube Pre-roll, and podcast advertising.
If you spend the next,
my friends, you can read
every quote I put on Instagram,
you can watch Tony's
documentary on Netflix
947 fucking times.
You can fucking go on
a retreat to an island,
meditate, fucking hire
me to personally consult
and sit by your, by the way,
your fucking outfit's fresh,
and sit by you,
sit by your fresh outfit
for 24 hours a day
and nothing I say for the next month,
will be better than the advice
I'm giving you right now,
which is figure out how you communicate.
You don't need to be like me,
not everybody is ridiculously charismatic
and good-looking on video.
(audience members cheering and applauding)
You might dominate writing.
You might be embarrassed
because of lighting or makeup
or you're just insecure visually.
Fine, I'm not even judging,
I don't give a shit.
Audio that shit, write, draw
pictures, I don't give a shit.
Go on a fucking mountain
and do smoke signals.
Figure out how to communicate
on LinkedIn, Facebook,
Instagram, Snapchat,
these platforms, podcasts.
How many people here consume
my content, raise your hand.
Thank you.
I know you know this,
I say it all the time.
Don't listen to what I'm
saying, watch what I'm doing.
Why am I putting out
content everywhere, always,
at a scale that has
never been seen before?
'Cause I know it's a moment in time.
I promise you, if you
find somebody who bought
a beachfront home in Malibu
when it was first coming up,
if you asked her what she thought about
that whole situation, the first
thing out of her mouth was,
I wish I bought a second home.
Because that 300,000 became 40 million.
There are moments when
things are under priced.
The number one asset in the world
is other people's attention.
Their attention is in play, it lives here.
Here are seven or eight
platforms named YouTube,
Facebook, Instagram, Snapchat, got it?
You need to figure out how to be in there.
Let me give you another
analogy because analogies work.
The internet is basically the highway.
The information superhighway
was a perfect analogy
back in the day.
It is the highway to our lives.
Facebook and Apple and
Google, they were so good
as companies, they figured
out how to be the toll booth
on those highways.
Every person in years job is to become
the best toll booth collector
inside that toll booth.
(audience applauding)
There is no shortcut,
there's no fucking hashtag
that you're gonna find it's
gonna fucking explode you.
Hashtag Andy is right.
What actually works is
the same shit that works
in everything in life.
Running an actual marathon.
Life is long.
Yes, I know you might get hit by bus.
Good news, if you get hit by a bus,
you're not gonna give a about anything.
(audience laughing)
Please start playing life as long.
Do you know many people
emailed me and said Gary,
I need your help, I'm desperate.
I bought a ton of fucking
Bitcoin at $15,000 a coin.
Everybody told me was gonna be a $100,000.
I maxed all my credit cards,
this, that, the other thing.
And, I reply, I'm like, why?
Why'd you do that?
And the answer is, it's
what always happens.
There's always Gold Rush.
People don't want to put in the work.
And I get that, they
have this imaginary thing
of how good it's gonna be.
DeRozan, the basketball
player for the Spurs,
who just got traded from the Raptors,
had a quote the other day.
"I wish everybody was
rich so they realized
"how much happiness, or not, it brings."
And there's a lot of truth to that.
Everybody's in a rush because
they don't realize that
loving the process is the game,
not the that the process gives you.
(audience applauding)
I make you the most
guaranteed promise ever.
If what you're doing
for a living right now
is a means to the money, you fucking lost.
You lost.
It's too hard to get to the
big money, you have to love it.
It's too hard because, if
you don't love real estate
but you're doing it 'cause you think
that's where the money is, the guy or gal
that loves real estate is
gonna beat your fucking ass.
It's just the way it is.
And, what's interesting to
me is, this is all happening
when the internet has
finally hit mass, mass scale.
It blows me away that you
could go literally buy apples,
apples wholesale
and relist them
and make money.
I know, dude, I'm using
this funny for a reason.
I don't think people realize,
here's what scares the shit out of me.
It's never been easier to make
$100,000 a year in America
if you do the following.
Spend 50 hours, I'm asking
you to spend 50 hours.
How many, tell the truth,
how many people here
would be happy to make $100,000 a year?
Raise your hand, I want to see the hands.
Raise them higher because this matters.
Can you stand, this matters
to me, please stand.
Please, this matters,
don't fucking be scared
because I know people
are fucking, oh shit,
it should be a million.
This is huge for me, I'm
really happy that people
are being honest 'cause a
lot of people like to front,
like no, billion or bust.
(audience laughing)
Stay up, listen to me.
This is more than 70%
of this room right now
based on my eye test, maybe 65,
that would be thrilled to make a hundred.
I know how hard it is to make a hundred.
(audience laughing)
I'm gonna tell you something that's gonna
blow your fucking face off.
And, I and I say this because I'm selfish,
because I do think one
of you that is standing
is gonna listen to me and do this.
And then, you're gonna
email me in 24 months.
if you just spend 50 to a hundred hours
educating yourself on
something you like or know,
books, sneakers, pants,
electronics, something, stuff.
We're gonna talk about selling right now,
and you study eBay and what
the price it goes for on eBay
in Buy It Nows and auctions,
buy it there and then send it to Amazon
and list on to Amazon,
if you spend 12 hours a day,
after spending a hundred
to 200 hours educating
yourself on a genre,
calculators, blouses,
purses, fucking I don't know,
tooth-fucking-paste!
If you spend a hundred to
200 hours understanding
the arbitrage that this
sneaker sells for 450 on eBay
but 580 on Amazon, and you
figure out how to buy it
at enough scale in Asia or Europe,
or you're buying wholesale
in Sydney, Australia
shipping to Amazon,
if you get educated on what's
called retail arbitrage,
you can sit at home, spend
10 hours a day working it,
like day trading, and I
genuinely believe 50%,
which is absurd, 50%
of the people standing
will hit their hundred thousand.
To me, that's crazy, it's so practical,
it takes some work, like I told you.
But yet people, you
can sit now, thank you.
It's practical.
It's practical, 70% of this
audience wants to make a hundo.
I genuinely know that
if you have the humility
to eat for three years, downsize,
you know many people I wish
sold their home right now
and went and rented,
because that's the crutch,
or that fucking BMW that you
have no reason fucking having,
but the only reason you
have it is because you want
to front in front of
people you don't even like?
(audience applauding)
If you have the humility
and the work ethic,
and the reason I want you to
do it around something you like
is searching calculators
for 12 hours a day,
if it's just for the money,
gets tedious and you'll break,
unless you love calculators.
Searching puzzles because
you fucking love puzzles
for 15 hours a day isn't tedious.
I'm telling you right now, literally,
I believe in this so much that yesterday,
I know some of you follow
me on social media,
yesterday, I spent
seven hours figuring out
that I think Charles Barkley
1986-87 Fleer rookie cards
are grossly under priced
in a 17-year window.
And I'm gonna invest heavy.
So, if you got any Berkeley rookies
graded nine and above, I'm interested.
That took me three hours and
I'm fucking happy and set.
That's how much I believe in the dirt.
My friends, if you want a hundo,
it's either become the
foremost expert in Snorks.
How many people know what a Snork is?
Fucking Smurfs in the sea.
(audience laughing)
Everyday, I just want
everybody understand,
every single day, I get DM'ed by 15 people
who are under 16 years
old, who have the humility
to stay in line at sneaker
stores and build their Instagram
and are making $10,000 a month in profit
flipping Yeezys and
Off-Whites and Jordans.
This is America in 2018.
There is nothing but money out there.
The problem is most
people aren't self-aware
to know who they are instead
of what they wish they were,
and most people didn't find something
that they're willing to
do for 18 hours a day
because they're looking for the money,
they're not looking for what they love.
Retail arbitrage or
building a media company,
a podcast a Youtube show,
an Instagram account,
around a long tail niche for
the next 24 to 36 months.
Patience, diligence.
Less Stranger Things,
marathons more studying Amazon.
Less fucking Fortnight,
more studying eBay.
Listen, you could be
Ninja if you want, but,
and by the way, it just comes down
to the level of happiness
but, I know one thing,
when 70% stand up for a hundo,
and I've never seen an era
that's easier to get to a hundo, easy.
15 hours a day.
200 hours upfront.
But when you fucking audit
the last 60 days of your life,
and think about all the fucking leisure
that you put in, and how that
got to 200 hours real quick,
and you're not totally pumped
and you want it so bad,
I'm fucking giving you, I'm giving you
the fishing pole right now.
Re-watch this shit.
I'm giving you the fishing pole.
The problem is, most of
you don't want to walk down
to the fucking lake and fish.
(audience applauding)
Apples, vegan, Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtle, sneakers,
everybody's talking about
billion dollar AI this,
machine learning that,
cryptocurrency this,
and 70% of the fuckers in
here wanna make a hundo.
I know you can do that by
literally picking up old VCRs
on Craigslist and flipping them on eBay,
but are you discipline and
humble and hungry enough
to get there?
That, my friends, comes when you tune out
everybody but yourself.
When you're not worried if
your friends are judging you
for buying cotton balls in
China and flipping it on Amazon,
you can get there.
And, I'm telling you right now,
if any of your fucking auntie
or grandmother, or wife,
if any of these fuck faces judge you,
send them to me, I'll
fucking set them straight!
Virginia, I fucking love you!
(audience cheering and applauding)
Let's go!
- [Announcer] Give a hand!